in order to survive in the world we have
little option but to spend our lives
being rather defended that is but one
remove from our more vulnerable sides
closed off from certain emotions focused
in many cases on not feeling and yet in
relationships quite the opposite is
required to be good at love means to
have a capacity to reveal one's hurt
desire and tender sides this is quite a
balancing act great strength for most of
the day and well handled tenderness for
the few that remain
it's no wonder if the journey from
independence to vulnerability can get
rather fraught and if the desire for
closeness can be accompanied by terror
and what looks like but isn't really
nastiness even after years with someone
there can be a hurdle of fear about
trying to get close to major symptoms
then tend to show up firstly we can get
distant or what psychotherapists call
avoidant we want to get close to our
partners but feel so anxious that we may
be unwanted we freeze them out a bit
instead we say we're busy we pretend our
thoughts are elsewhere we imply that a
need for reassurance would be the last
thing on our minds we might even have an
affair the ultimate face-saving attempt
to be safely distant and often a
perverse quest to assert that we don't
require the partners love a love that
we've been too reserved to ask for or
else we can get controlling what
therapists called anxious we feel our
partners are escaping us emotionally and
we respond by trying to pin them down
administratively we get unduly cross at
they're a bit late we chastise them
heavily for not having done certain
chores we ask them constantly if they've
completed a task they'd agreed to
undertake all this rather than admit I'm
worried I don't matter to you we can't
we believe force our partner to be
generous and warm we can't force them to
want us even if we haven't actually
asked them to so we try to control them
procedurally a tragic cycle then unfolds
we become shrill and unpleasant to the
other person it feels that we can't
possibly love them anymore
yet the truth is we do we just fear
rather too
much that they don't love us but if our
rather harsh
graceless behavior could be truly
understood for what it is it would be
revealed not as rejection but as a
strangely distorted yet very real plea
for tenderness we should have sympathy
for ourselves relationships require us
to put ourselves in a very weak position
visa fee partners if they ever want to
use the power they have over us and
sometimes they do they know exactly
where to put the boot in this can be
deeply frightening this aspect of
relationships is even more difficult if
our early experiences and childhoods
have made closeness rather scary if
we've encountered people who've taken
signs of vulnerability as targets so
we're not frightened of closeness
because we're fools but because it is a
challenge to be around another person
who might easily hurt us and to keep on
in a relationship despite the fact that
they do sometimes use this knowledge to
strike out at us closeness is inherently
threatening but we can gradually with
courage and difficulty replace defense
with explanation we can say we're
frightened and why rather than turn cold
or controlling and we can begin to see
what our partners might be trying to
communicate through their off-putting
behavior we can never be through with a
requirement for acceptance this isn't a
curse limited to the weak and to the
inadequate in security and love is a
sign of well-being
it means we haven't allowed ourselves to
take another person for granted it means
we remain realistic enough to see that
things could genuinely turn out badly
and that were invested enough to care we
must get better at seeing the love and
longing that lurk behind some of our and
our partners most frosty managerial and
brutish moments we just in our own way
dealing with the anxieties of trying to
get close
you